Surnommé « le président poète »,
il parlait d’un nouvel humanisme,
une civilisation universelle
où toutes les cultures se réuniraient autour d’une table,
égaux,
chacun apportant sa belle contribution.
Il l’a appelé « le rendez-vous de donner et de recevoir ».
Ce concept a résonné en moi,
et il a guidé mon parcours professionnel.
Après des années à travailler dans des restaurants,
j’espérais que mon travail aurait un impact plus profond,
qui irait au-delà du dernier repas que j’avais servi.
Je voulais redonner et à New York,
la ville qui m’a donné l’occasion de suivre ma vocation,
et à mes origines et à mes ancêtres au Sénégal.
Je voulais contribuer à cette civilisation universelle
que Senghor avait décrite.
Mais je ne savais pas comment avoir un impact mesurable
en tant que cuisinier et écrivain.
Pendant que j’écrivais mon premier livre de recettes,
je me suis rendu dans différentes régions du Sénégal pour mes recherches.
Pendant un de ces voyages,
dans une lointaine région du Sud-Est appelée Kédougou,
j’ai redécouvert une céréale ancienne appelée fonio,
qui avait presque disparu de l’alimentation urbaine sénégalaise.
Il s’avère que le fonio avait été cultivé
pendant plus de 5 000 ans,
et c'est probablement la plus ancienne céréale cultivée en Afrique.
Autrefois connu de la plus grande partie du continent,
le Fonio était cultivé jusqu'en Égypte ancienne,
où les archéologues ont trouvé des graines
à l’intérieur des tombes près des pyramides.
Aujourd’hui, il est surtout cultivé dans la partie occidentale du Sahel,
du Sénégal au Mali,
Burkina Faso,
Togo, Nigeria.
Le Sahel est cette zone semi-aride au sud du Sahara,
qui s’étend de l’Atlantique à l’Ouest, jusqu'à la mer Rouge à l’Est.
Je me suis de plus en plus intéressé à cette céréale,
que les Égyptiens prenaient la peine d'emmener dans l’au-delà.
En continuant mes recherches,
j’ai découvert qu'en fait,
partout où il était cultivé,
le fonio était toujours rattaché à un mythe ou à une superstition.
Les Dogon,
une autre grande culture au Mali,
l'appelaient « Po »,
ou « la graine de l’univers ».
Dans la mythologie de cette culture ancienne,
l’univers entier a germé d’une graine de fonio.
En dehors de ses prétendues propriétés mystiques,
le fonio est un céréale miraculeuse sous bien des aspects.
Il est nutritif,
particulièrement riche en méthionine et en cystéine,
deux acides aminés qui manquent dans la plupart des céréales,
l’orge, le riz ou le blé pour ne nommer qu'eux.
En plus,
la culture du fonio est géniale pour l’environnement.
Il tolère les terres pauvres
et a besoin de très peu d’eau,
survivant là où rien d’autre ne peut pousser.
En tant que chef,
ce qui m’a d’abord marqué était son goût délicat et sa polyvalence.
Similaire au couscous,
le fonio a un goût délicieux de noisettes et de terre.
Il peut être transformé en salade,
servi comme nouilles,
utilisé dans la pâtisserie,
ou simplement comme substitut pour toute autre céréale
dans vos recettes préférées.
Je suis heureux de partager mon sushi au fonio
et mon sushi à la patate douce
avec certains d’entre vous en ce moment.
Public : Oh !
(Applaudissements)
Et Okra.
(Murmures)
À Kédougou,
il est aussi surnommé « ñamu buur »,
ce qui signifie « nourriture pour la royauté »,
et il est servi pour les invités d’honneur.
Situé à la frontière avec la Guinée et le Mali,
Kédougou marque d’abord les visiteurs par ses superbes panoramas
et vues des montagnes du Fouta Djallon.
Malheureusement, c’est aussi l’une des plus pauvres régions du Sénégal.
En raison de la désertification et du manque de perspectives d’emploi,
une grande partie de la jeunesse du Kédougou est partie.
Ils ont choisi la voie mortelle de la migration,
à la recherche de « meilleures » opportunités.
Souvent,
ils risquent leur vie en essayant d’atteindre l’Europe.
Certains partent en traversant le Sahara.
D’autres se retrouvent sur des canots en bois inadaptés,
dans une tentative désespérée d'atteindre l’Espagne.
Selon un récent article dans « The Guardian »,
en 2020, plus de 60 millions de personnes d’Afrique subsaharienne auront migré,
en raison de la désertification.
C’est la plus grande vague de migration au niveau mondial
depuis la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
et elle ne fait qu'augmenter.
Jusqu’à présent, cette année,
plus de 2 100 migrants ont perdu la vie
sur leur chemin vers l’Europe.
C’est la réalité de Kédougou
et de la majeure partie du Sahel aujourd’hui.
Avenir effrayant,
nourriture rare
et aucune opportunité pour changer leur situation.
Si la vie dans votre village n’était pas si précaire,
s’il y avait un moyen d'avoir assez de nourriture pour vivre,
ou avoir un travail rémunéré,
si vous et vos sœurs ne deviez pas passer 30% de votre temps éveillé
à aller puiser de l’eau,
si les conditions étaient juste un peu plus hospitalières...
Et si la solution se trouvait déjà ici, dans notre sol ?
Et si la diffusion du fonio au reste du monde
était la solution ?
Les anciennes céréales sont de plus en plus populaires
et les ventes d’articles sans gluten sont en croissance aux États-Unis -
+16,4% depuis 2013,
ce qui en fait une industrie de 23,3 milliards de dollars.
Comment est-ce que le fonio peut rentrer dans ce marché ?
Il y a beaucoup de défis pour transformer le fonio en nourriture.
Le processus traditionnel est laborieux et chronophage,
surtout quand on le compare avec d’autres céréales.
Eh bien, heureusement, la technologie a évolué.
Et il y a maintenant des machines
qui peuvent traiter le fonio d’une manière plus efficace.
Et en fait,
il y a quelques années,
Sanoussi Diakité,
un ingénieur sénégalais,
a remporté un prix Rolex
pour l'invention du premier processeur mécanisé de fonio.
Aujourd’hui, de telles machines rendent la vie beaucoup plus facile
aux producteurs dans toute la région du Sahel.
Un autre défi est la mentalité coloniale selon laquelle
ce qui vient de l’Occident est meilleur.
Cette tendance à dévaloriser nos propres produits
et à voir des vivres comme le fonio simplement comme
« de la nourriture de paysans »
donc un sous-produit,
explique pourquoi,
même si nous ne produisons pas traditionnellement de blé au Sénégal,
on trouve plus facilement des baguettes ou des croissants dans les rues de Dakar,
que de trouver des produits à base de fonio.
Ce même état d’esprit a popularisé les restes de riz,
débris connus sous le nom de « riz cassé ».
Il a été importé au Sénégal d’Indochine
et introduit par les Français.
Très vite, le riz cassé est devenu un ingrédient clé de notre plat national,
le thiéboudienne,
remplaçant notre riz africain traditionnel, plus nutritif,
Oryza glaberrima.
Ironiquement, ce même riz africain, méprisé chez soi,
a été apprécié à l’étranger.
En effet, pendant le commerce des esclaves,
ce riz est devenu une céréale majeure dans les Amériques,
particulièrement dans les Carolines,
où il a été surnommé « Carolina Gold » [L'Or des Carolines].
Mais revenons au fonio.
Comment pouvons-nous évoluer son statut actuel,
« nourriture de paysans »,
vers un grain de classe mondiale ?
L’année dernière,
un partenaire d’affaires et moi avons conclu un accord
avec Whole Foods Market,
la plus grande chaîne de magasins d’aliments bios des États-Unis,
pour y vendre du fonio.
Et nous avons rencontré un grand importateur d’ingrédients américain
assez intéressé pour envoyer une équipe de cadres
en Afrique de l’Ouest avec nous
pour vérifier la faisabilité de la chaîne d’approvisionnement.
Nous nous sommes retrouvés en train d’observer les opérations manuelles
dans des endroits éloignés,
avec peu de contrôles sur la qualité.
Nous avons donc commencé à nous concentrer sur les problèmes de traitement.
Nous avons élaboré une vision
avec une chaîne d’approvisionnement rentable et durable pour le fonio
et nous avons pris contact avec des organisations
qui pouvaient nous aider à l’atteindre.
En partant du marché, voici à quoi cela peut ressembler.
Imaginez que le fonio soit consommé partout dans le monde,
comme d’autres céréales classiques.
Le fonio promu au même niveau que les céréales,
pains,
barres nutritives,
biscuits, pâtes,
collations.
Pourquoi pas ?
C’est plus facile à dire que « quinoa ».
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Pour y arriver,
le fonio doit être facilement disponible
à une qualité constante pour être commercialisable,
par l'industrie alimentaire et les chaînes de restaurants.
C’est la partie qui nous manque.
Pour rendre le fonio disponible à une qualité constante
pour un usage commercial,
vous avez besoin d’un moulin à fonio à l’échelle commerciale,
qui adhère aux normes internationales de qualité.
Actuellement, ce type de moulin n'existe nulle part
donc dans notre vision,
il y a un moulin à fonio appartenant et exploité par les Africains
qui traite efficacement
et en conformité avec les exigences des multinationales de l'alimentaire.
Aujourd'hui, il est très difficile pour les producteurs de fonio
de vendre et utiliser le fonio,
à moins qu’ils ne consacrent une énorme quantité de temps et d’énergie
en le battant, vannant et le décortiquant.
Dans notre vision,
le moulin assumera ces tâches,
permettant aux producteurs de se concentrer sur l’agriculture
plutôt que sur la transformation.
Il y a un potentiel agricole inexploité au Sahel,
et il suffit juste de changer les conditions du marché
pour activer cette capacité.
En soulageant les producteurs de fonio des opérations manuelles,
le moulin va leur libérer du temps
et supprimer le goulot de la production qui limite leur production.
Et il y a aussi d’autres avantages
en utilisant les terres sahéliennes pour l’agriculture.
Plus d’avantages,
plus d’emplois,
atténuation du changement climatique en combattant la désertification,
et une meilleure sécurité alimentaire.
Belle vision, non ?
Eh bien, nous travaillons pour que cela devienne réalité.
Le mois dernier, nous avons présenté le fonio à des clients new-yorkais
ainsi qu'en ligne,
dans un emballage qui le rend attrayant, aguichant et accessible.
(Applaudissements)
Nous parlons avec les opérateurs et investisseurs en Afrique de l’Ouest
sur la construction d’un moulin à fonio.
Et surtout,
nous avons fait équipe avec une ONG appelée SOS SAHEL
pour recruter, former et équiper les petites entreprises au Sahel
pour augmenter leur production de fonio.
Les niveaux de famine sont plus élevés en Afrique subsaharienne
que n’importe où dans le monde.
La population du Sahel devrait croître
de 135 à 340 millions de personnes.
Cependant, dans cette région sujette à la sécheresse et la famine,
le fonio se développe librement.
Cette petite céréale peut fournir de grandes réponses,
réaffirmant son nom dogon,
« Po », la graine de l’univers,
et nous rapprochant d'un pas
de la civilisation universelle.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)